we generally think that philosophers
should be proud of their big brains and
be fans of thinking self-reflection and
rational analysis but there's one
philosopher born in france in 1533 who
had a refreshingly different take
michel de montagne was an intellectual
who spent his writing life knocking the
arrogance of intellectuals in his great
masterpiece the essays he comes across
as relentlessly wise and intelligent but
also as constantly modest and keen to
debunk the pretensions of learning not
least he's extremely funny reminding his
readers to learn that we have said or
done a stupid thing is nothing we must
learn a more ample and important lesson
that we are but blockheads
or as he put it on the highest throne in
the world we are seated still upon our
motein was a child of the renaissance
and the ancient philosophers popular in
mountains day believed that our powers
of reason could afford us a happiness
and greatness denied to other creatures
reason was a sophisticated almost divine
tool offering us mastery over the world
in ourselves that was the line taken by
philosophers like cicero but this
characterization of human reason enraged
montane
after hanging out with academics and
philosophers he wrote in practice
thousands of little women in their
villages have lived more gentle more
equitable and more constant lives than
cicero
his point wasn't that human beings can't
reason at all simply that they tend to
be far too arrogant about the limits of
their brains
as he wrote our life consists partly in
madness partly in wisdom whoever writes
about it merely respectfully and by rule
leaves more than half of it behind
perhaps the most obvious example of our
madness is the struggle of living within
a human body our bodies smell ache sag
pulse throb and age whatever the desires
of our minds
moltain was the world's first and
possibly only philosopher to talk at
length about impotence which seemed to
him a prime example of how crazy and
fragile our minds are moutain had a
friend who'd grown impotent with a woman
he particularly liked moutain didn't
blame the penis the problem was the mind
the oppressive notion that we had
complete control over our bodies and the
horror of departing from this
theoretical normality
the solution montane said was to redraw
our sense of what's normal by accepting
a loss of command over the penis as a
harmless common possibility in
lovemaking one could preempt its
occurrence as the stricken man
eventually discovered in bed with a
woman he learned to admit beforehand
that he was subject to this infirmity
and spoke openly about it so relieving
the tensions within his soul by bearing
the malady as something to be expected
his sense of constriction grew less and
weighed less heavily upon him
mortein's fatness allows the tensions in
the reader's own soul to be relieved a
man who failed with his girlfriend could
regain his forces and soothe the
anxieties of his beloved by accepting
that his impotence belonged to a broad
realm of sexual mishaps neither very
rare nor very peculiar mortain was
equally frank about the limitations of
his intellect and of its usefulness
academia was deeply prestigious in
moltain's day as in our own
yet although moltain was an excellent
scholar he hated pedentry and academia
he only wanted to learn things that were
useful and relentlessly attacked
academics for being out of touch
if man were wise he would gauge the true
worth of anything by its usefulness and
appropriateness to his life he said only
that which makes us feel better may be
worth understanding in this vein maute
mocked books that were difficult to read
he admitted to his readers that he found
plato more than a little boring and that
he just wanted to have fun with books
i'm not prepared to bash my brains out
for anything not even for learning's
sake however precious it may be from
books all i seek is to get myself some
pleasure by an honorable pastime if i
come across some difficult passages in
my reading i don't bite my nails over
them after making a charge or two i let
them be if one book tires me i just take
up another
he could be pretty caustic about
incomprehensible philosophers difficulty
is a coin which the learned conjure with
so as not to reveal the vanity of their
studies and which human stupidity is
keen to accept in payment
morten observed how an intimidating
scholarly culture has made all of us
study other people's books way before we
study our own minds and yet as he put it
we are richer than we think each one of
us
maute is refreshing because he describes
a life which is recognizably like our
own and yet inspiring still he is a very
human ideal we may all arrive at wise
ideas if we cease to think of ourselves
as unsuited to the task just because we
aren't 2000 years old or aren't
interested in the topics of plato's
dialogues or have a so-called ordinary
life
montain reassures us you can attach the
whole of moral philosophy to a
commonplace private life just as well as
to one with richer stuff
in montane's redrawn portrait of the
adequate semi-rational human being it's
possible to speak no greek change one's
mind after a meal get bored with a book
be impotent and know pretty much none of
the ancient philosophers a virtuous
ordinary life striving for wisdom but
never far from folly is achievement
enough
mortein remains the great readable
intellectual with whom we can laugh at
intellectuals and pretensions of many
kinds he was a breath of fresh air in
the cloistered unworldly snobbish
corridors of the academia of the 16th
century and because academia has sadly
not changed very much he continues to be
an inspiration and a solace to all of us
who feel routinely oppressed and
patronized by the pedentry and arrogance
of so-called clever people